the third fight between these great
rivals was their most riveting with five
knockdowns in total deontay wilder went
down first and looked to be hanging on
at the end of the third round but he
turned the fight on its head in the
fourth sending tyson fury to the canvas
twice
thanks to his powerful right hand
but the briton prevailed when wilder
went down face first in the penultimate
round
fury retaining his title
this tonight was one of my greatest uh
wins
um i got off the floor to do it and um
you know i'm the big dog in the division
in the ring size matters ask a man who's
fought fury twice he's very tall so
every time he moves back you think you
are rich and he then you go again he
hits you the jab
you know he's a he's a beast of a man
las vegas was the glittering destination
but the journey started here in
manchester wow he's an absolute giant
yes he's a big lad
fury was just 14 when he first came into
steve eagan's gym and for the coach
this fight was his best ever
i always told him i mean you're going to
be everywhere in charge of the world and
he always said to me you know i mean i
believe in you steve and you believe in
me
um me and you steve top of the world and
and you go with it don't you thinking
yeah yeah we're going to do it
roll right left right again one more
go
at this gym they've watched fury's every
move now they want to see him take
titles held by alexander usic
to become the first undisputed
heavyweight world champion since lennox
lewis in 2000
satya choudhary sky news